people of the internet retrorecontour
here and happy monday to you hogwarts
legacy fans at least that is what
playstation just said when they dropped
a tweet out of nowhere announcing a
state of play for this thursday march
17th at 2 p.m pacific time that's going
to be 5 p.m eastern time and holy wow
you guys state of play not just a normal
state of play a state of play dedicated
to hogwarts legacy here's the exact
wording of the tweet one's at the ready
for an all-new state of play focused on
hogwarts legacy featuring an extended
first look at
gameplay you guys we did it it is
finally here uh we have finally made it
to the big reveal i mean this is i think
this is going to be bigger than the
original trailer i got to be honest this
is the big reveal we've been speculating
for months for years even on this game
and if you can't tell this video is
completely off the cuff i just wanted to
get something out there to you guys
letting you know yes i've seen the news
yes i'm super excited we're gonna have
more stuff leading up all week to this
but if you didn't notice there actually
is a link with the playstation tweet as
well so if you hit the link it takes you
to the playstation blog where there is a
post from chandler wood the community
manager for the game and who knows i may
be putting this video out too early we
may get more stuff today from chandler
wood from the official hogwarts legacy
channels i don't know but even so i
think the big reveal is obviously coming
this thursday but uh here is what it
says on the playstation blog so at least
the high points here
they talk about how the original trailer
has been viewed more than 28 million
times which has it
right up there among the top three top
four videos on the playstation the
entire channel which is insane now
here's the big incredible piece of this
guys the show will run for about 20
minutes
featuring over 14 minutes
of hogwarts legacy gameplay captured on
ps5 and concluding with some insight
from a few members of the team at
avalanche software who are bringing the
wizarding world
uh to life i thought they meant to say
title there but i think they just
bringing the wizarding world to life
join us this thursday and then it also
says don't forget to head back here to
the playstation blog afterward for a
special post that will add a little more
context to what we're about to show you
so
i mean i i just i can't believe this
it's it's
we've been talking about it we've been
speculating we've been wondering like
what are they doing here you know and we
were wondering is it going to be kind of
a steady trickle of information
no here we go they are just taking the
lid off this game 14 minutes of gameplay
you guys i mean can you imagine how much
coverage we're gonna have here on the
channel can you imagine how many
breakdowns we will be able to do of 14
minutes of gameplay footage and then it
said not only that then they're gonna
have some devs come on and talk the show
is gonna be about 20 minutes long solely
dedicated to this game and then after
that there's going to be a follow-up
playstation blog post that allows even
more information
now there's also a little piece at the
very bottom of this about co-streaming
and video on demand and it does say
please note this broadcast may include
copyrighted content including music that
playstation doesn't control so
i'm yet to decide if i'm going to be
doing a live stream of this i'm going to
read a little bit more and maybe we'll
see if chandler wood puts out some
information on that because i definitely
don't want to live stream and then
get it taken down or get the video where
you guys can't even see it so we'll see
um but i would love to do a live stream
of this i think this is just an
incredible moment for the hogwarts
legacy community
i think considering this is such a huge
reveal i think we're undoubtedly going
to get a release date here as well i
mean if we don't i still don't think
it's a huge deal maybe it'll be more
like a release window maybe like a just
a time like a month instead of an exact
day
but clearly if they're getting ready to
show this much then i think they are
fully ready to finally talk about this
game i'm incredibly excited i know you
guys are excited as well let me know in
the comments below what are you most
excited to see in the gameplay is it
spells is it how you move about the
world is it how the characters look is
it how the graphics have changed i mean
what are you most excited for and if you
guys are new i mean some of you may not
have been
uh even looking at all the hogwarts
legacy news and it hasn't been much but
there have been little trickles of
rumors and information that we've been
covering here on this channel check out
the video on the right side of your
screen now that's going to get you all
caught up because we have a full
playlist of hogwarts legacy videos here
on the channel as always thank you all
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again very very soon